[MUSIC PLAYING]
ILYA GELFENBEYN:
Today, we will be
talking about
designing, deploying
your agents across platforms,
and then analyzing them.
So my name is Ilya.
I'm the Product Lead of API.AI.
API.AI is Google's platform for
building conversational apps
or agents for Google Assistant,
Google Home, and also
all the other platforms
through API or integration.
So you can also build
a chatbot with it,
or add voice to your robot
car, or any other home device.
In a few minutes,
I will show you
how to build a conversational
agent from scratch
and deploy it across platforms.
And Ofer will tell you how to
analyze it and optimize it.
OFER RONEN: Thanks.
So I am Ofer, the
Product Lead on Chatbase.
It's an up-and-coming
service that
helps developers
analyze and optimize
conversational experiences.
And so, today, I'm
going to go over
how Chatbase can help
developers with key metrics
and workflows that
can help you create
engaging and high-converting
conversational agents.
ILYA GELFENBEYN: OK.
But let's first
think why would you
start building a
conversational agent.
So let's say you are building
a online bagel ordering
app or service.
So now, what you will
be actually caring about
is to get a really great
app for Android and iPhone,
and probably a popular
web service for it.
But it seems like it's
not enough anymore.
So as you can see,
analysts predict
that voice interfaces and
natural language interfaces
will be extremely popular.
So by 2020, more than 30% of
all the web browsing sessions
will be done without a screen.
Meaning that while
users will be asking
their requests through home
devices or cars, or assistance.
More than 50% of all the web
searches will be done by voice.
So through, again, mobile
assistants or some other apps.
And more than 85% of all
the customer interactions
with brands will be
done without a human,
through chatbots
or anything else.
So basically, your
users will expect
you to be able to
provide service
through a conversational
agent and not just
a mobile app or a web service.
So this is why we are
working on API.AI.
So what is important about it?
It is an extremely
popular platform
to build conversational agents
across different platforms.
We have more than
150,000 developers
working with the platform.
It supports 14
different languages.
So you can now start building
your agent for English,
Spanish, Portuguese, French,
Chinese, Korean, Japanese.
And we are adding new
languages constantly.
And what is extremely
important about it,
as I already mentioned,
it is cross-platform.
So you can build your
agent in one place
and then deploy it across
multiple platforms.
So why is it important?
So one thing which is extremely
important is, as you know,
while there are multiple
different platforms out there
which have audience,
so you may have
like a Facebook bot
or a home device
or some kind of an assistant.
And let's say if
you are an agent
and you service to
your product, it
may be extremely difficult
to update your agent across
for each individual
platform, so it makes sense
to have everything in one place.
Second, and probably the most
important thing is training.
And I mean both manual
training and machine learning.
So if we talk about
manual training,
let's say, well, you
have your agent deployed
across different
platforms and while you
get some logs from real users,
and you are analyzing them
and optimizing your agent.
So having it all in one
place makes a lot of sense
because if you
update something, it
will be available across
all the platforms.
So basically all the
platforms benefit
from all the
interactions with you,
as your agent or product has.
Another one is related
to machine learning.
So in order to train a really
good machine learning model
to understand what users
actually want and support
a meaningful
conversation, you have
to provide it with
real life data,
like logs that you mark up.
And if you have the data in
different several platforms,
it may be much less
beneficial than having
everything in one place.
So building a very
sophisticated training
set for your agent
to better understand.
And third, while natural
language is unique as a UX
media because you cannot really
control what users will be
asking about, so you cannot
tell that my service, well,
my chatbot implementation
of service supports these
commands, and my home
implementation supports those.
So users are not limited by any
sets of commands, or anything,
so they can ask
about everything.
So you really want to
have a consistent UX
across all the platforms.
But let's switch to
the demo and I will
show how to build the agent.
So this is the
developer console.
So this is where you get when
you register with API.AI.
I just created an empty agent.
And I will show how to build
your bagel ordering app
from scratch.
So as you can see, well,
there are two main concepts
in API.AI.
One is Intents, and
another one is Entities.
So Intents are types of actions
that you want to support.
So what my user
may ask me about.
And Entities are
objects that are
being used in these Intents.
So as you can see,
there are a couple
of intents that are pre-build.
One is a Fallback Intent.
So if system doesn't
understand, it
will trigger Fallback
Intent, so it
can say, "Well, I
don't understand,
can you rephrase it?"
Or something like this.
And you can obviously
customize it.
Second one is Welcome Intent.
So this one is triggered
when you start your agent
from Google Assistant
or Facebook bot,
or like Slack bot
or something else.
So it also has some
pre-built responses.
I can actually update and
it will say, "Greetings,
I am your bagel agent."
So I save it.
And then lets just create
our first Custom Intent.
So for bagel ordering service,
it will be bagel ordering.
So I can tell something like--
well, so here I am defining how
my end users may address it.
So My end user might
just say, "I'm hungry."
or something like "Get
me a bagel by 2 PM."
And as you can see, the dual
name mintage recognition.
So we mark up 2 PM as time.
Or let's say, I can
say something like,
"I'd like to order bagels
to 123 East street."
And it understands
it is an address.
And, let's say, we'll say
something like, "Why don't we
order some bagels?"
So if my user says
something like this,
we will return an action order.
And it will also return
the result parameters.
And we will-- let's call
it Bagel Order Intent.
And we will reply with
something like, "OK.
Ordered."
And I save it.
So as you can see here, I'm
providing a default response
here.
So if my user will ask to do
it, it will just respond, "OK.
Ordered."
So in real life, you would want
to connect it to your business
logic, to your service.
So you can implement
a Fulfillment.
So you can set up
which service to call.
And so now, we can try it.
So I can say something
basic like, "I'm so hungry."
What happens is, it says,
OK, so this is the JSON
that the operator will get.
So user asked "I'm so hungry."
and you return an Action Order
and there are no parameters
here.
Or I can try something else.
I can say something like,
"I want to buy a bagel."
again, it understands it.
And what is important
here, what's
the first magic here is that,
well, the phrase that I'm using
does not really look
like the phrases
that I was using in the demo.
So the system, the
Intent recognition part
will try to understand and try
to classify anything that is
similar to what you provided.
So this is like understanding
single commands.
But obviously, we want
to support some kind
of conversation with the user.
So let's make it a little
bit more complicated.
So instead of "OK.
Ordered."
we will reply
something like, "OK.
Would you like to
have a drink with it?"
I save it.
And in order to support
this conversation,
I will want to create
some Intents that
work in the context
of this question.
So there is an easy way
to do it automatically.
So I can tell add a follow-up
intent to the bagel order.
And I will choose
Select a Confirmation.
And I can also just create
a custom empty intent.
So Create Confirmation.
And, let's say I'll
create a rejection.
And I'll customize those.
So I'll call it "Drink confirm."
And as you can see, it
has an input context.
So this is a topic
that starts when
the user asks to order a bagel.
So we have this bagel
order contacts active now.
And if user confirms, and there
is a set of some confirmation
phrases, then we will reply
with something like "Great.
Your order is on its way."
So let's save it.
And then, we will also
rename our second intent
and we'll call it
"Order reject."
sorry, "Drink reject".
So you can also
create these contexts
and manage contexts
automatically.
So let's say we want to make it
possible for the user to check
their status order at any time.
So I'm going to my main
bagel order intent.
And I will add
Ordering context here.
And it is possible
to set the lifespan.
So we are basically trying
to emulate human memory,
so you may have a limited
number of topics that
are active at the same time.
And they will expire if
you're not talking about it
for a while.
And they will be
refreshed if user
keeps talking about something.
So I save it.
And then I will create
a new intent that
will be called "Oder Status."
And that you will work in
the context of ordering,
and if my user says
"Where are my bagels?"
or, "What's the order status?"
Then, it will return status
action to the app developer,
and then the developer will
implement the business logic
here.
So let's try it again.
So I can say something like,
"I want to buy a bagel."
so you can see that
it responds with "OK.
Would you like to
have a drink with it?"
I can say, "Sure."
and it says, "Yes.
The order is on its way."
So this is a really basic
way to build conversations.
But let's say my user--
well, my agent cannot understand
the user because the user is
asking something very different.
So I can tell
something like Take--
well, "My usual order, please."
Let's see if it works.
Yeah.
So it responds with
Fallback Intent.
It says, "I didn't get that.
Can you say it again?"
so you, as a developer, can
go to the Training section.
See your logs, and
see that, well,
if user says something
like this, may be I
will assign a
bagel order intent.
So I prove it, and
now, if I again say,
"My usual order, please."
It will actually proceed
with the bagel order routine.
Now, with context you can
build these conversations.
But you cannot
really think, well,
create a pre-built
dialogue three.
So you cannot think of all
the possible ways of ordering
bagels.
So there are some
optimization techniques.
One is Slot Filling.
So let me show how it works.
But first, I will create
a couple of entities.
So let's say we want
to order bagel types.
Type.
So have a plain bagel, and
Asiago bagel, and sesame bagel,
let's say.
So I save this entity.
I can also create fillings.
Let's have salmon here.
And I can add some synonyms.
So it can be also
called lox, for example.
Or I'll have also
tomatoes or cucumbers.
And the final one
will be spreads.
So I may have cream
cheese, or mustard, or jam.
OK.
I save it.
So now, I can get back to
my bagel ordering intent.
And by the way, so everything
that I've shown here also
is available through API.
So you can on-the-fly update
your Intents and Entities.
You can create end
user-specific entities.
So if it's like,
say, end users' list
of favorite artists
or an address book,
you can also take
it into account.
So let me add some more
interesting examples.
So I can say
something like, "I'd
like to order five bagels
with cream cheese."
so it figures out
that five is a number,
cream cheese is a spread.
And I can also say, "I want
an Asiago bagel with salmon."
so it figures out the
type and the fillings.
And so, here, let's say, I want
to get the type and filling
and spread always from the
user in order to order.
So I can check them as required.
And let's say I have
several fillings,
so I will say that
this is the list.
So I save it.
And let's start again.
So I say something
like, "I want a bagel."
it takes some time to
train, or I'm just hungry.
So as you can see, it figures
out that the action is ordered,
but there are no
parameters filled.
And it starts
asking me questions,
like, "What's the spread?"
And you can reply
one by one, but it
may be pretty difficult to do.
Well, it's hard to
expect from end users
to follow your instructions.
So they can all reply
in different order.
They can combine
parameters, and so on.
So I can say
something like, well,
"I've always preferred sesame
bagels/" So, as you can see,
type is "sesame" now,
but it keeps asking me
what's the spread.
And I can obviously customize
the prompt, as well.
So I can ask something like
what kind of bagel is it,
or anything like this.
Or I can also reply
with something like,
"My mom would like
cream cheese."
well, actually say,
"lox and tomato."
again, I'm not responding
to this question.
But what happens
if it figures out
that the fillings are
salmon and tomatoes.
And then, let's finally
tell what's the spread.
So I say, cream
cheese is my favorite.
It figures out the spread
and now, all the required
parameters are filled, so it
keeps going with the drink.
I can say, yep.
And order is on the way.
So, I've built this basic agent.
So the next step for
me would be to deploy
to different platforms.
So I can go to integrations.
And again, you can just use API.
So to deploy to any
type of platform.
But we have easy-to-use
integrations
to popular platforms.
So let's start with, Actions
on Google, of course.
So I go to Create a
Project in the console.
So then I go back and say test.
I will open the simulator.
And I can see something like,
well, "Talk to my test app."
I don't need to re-sign in.
OK.
So it replies, "Greetings.
I'm your bagel agent."
As you may remember, this
is our welcome intent.
So I'll say, "I'm hungry."
and it starts asking
me all the questions.
So similarly, I can enable
a web demo, for example.
I can set a name for it.
So let's say it's
my IO bagel demo.
So this is my agent, again.
I'm hungry.
Cancel.
And by the way, I can also make
it much more conversational
by enabling small talk.
So if I say, "Hi, now."
it doesn't understand me.
I can go and enable
small talk here.
And I can customize it.
So, let's say, if
asks, "Who are you?"
I will reply "I am IO
Bagel Ordering system."
Save.
So if Small Talk is
enabled, I can try it again.
Say, "Hi."
"Hi there, friend"
"Who are you?"
Oops.
Takes some time to train.
Anyway, you got the idea.
So and then, let's also enable
some sort of budget platform.
Let's say, Slack.
So I go to Slack,
say, Test on Slack.
Enable it for my group.
It takes some time
to check the status.
OK.
That mode is activated.
And yes.
So I've got this API bot.
So same stuff.
I can say, "Hi."
It takes some time to launch it.
Like, let's say--
"Hungry."
I guess I was using it for
another demo, and that's--
oh, yeah.
So it replies to me now.
So this is all good.
So what is interesting
and what was announced
at this event is that,
well, now Google Assistant
is also available for Androids
and iPhones, which actually
makes you build
agents that will be
available to a much larger
audience, which is great.
So let's say we will
build this agent
and that it is voice-only.
As you can see, it doesn't
reply with some white cards
or anything like this.
So I can go back and upgrade it.
So I'm going to my,
say, bagel order.
And add an Actions on
Google integration.
And I will say something like--
so for the drink
information, we will
add some suggestions shapes.
And it will be like,
"Sure" or "Nope"
and then, when I'm going
into Drink Confirmation,
I will also add a picture here.
Hmm, yummy.
Save it.
And let's try it again.
OK.
Cancel the previous
conversation.
OK.
Talk to my desktop.
Greetings.
I'm hungry.
Oops, I didn't save it, I guess.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I have to reply, so
let's say, cream cheese and--
what's the type?
sesame.
And fillings, salmon.
So as you can see, it edited the
"sure" and "nope" suggestions.
So I say, "Sure".
And it will respond with
the answer and the card.
You can also add galleries
and some other types
of rich content and it
can connect transactions.
So by the way, the simulator,
as soon as you start testing it,
it is also available on
your physical device.
As your new home
or a pixel device,
for example, or Android.
So this is how you build
and deploy rich agents
across different platforms.
And when the agent is
deployed, well, next step
you would want to see how
real users are actually
talking into it, and Ofer
will be talking about it.
So how you analyze
it and optimize it.
Yes.
OK.
OFER RONEN: OK.
Well.
Thanks, Ilya.
ILYA GELFENBEYN: Thank you.
OFER RONEN: Well.
First, I want to
apologize for talking
about the bagels with cream
cheese, slightly warm,
all before lunch.
So sorry about that.
Good news, people
building agents on API.AI
now have analytics.
There's a new tab that is there.
And it shows you the
volume of sessions
that you had for your agent.
And also, how deep into the
conversation the users went.
So the kind of engagement.
And then, pro-intent.
For example, ordering bagel.
You can see metrics,
including how often
did the user leave the
session right after an intent.
And so you can really
understand what's broken
and what to optimize.
So that's the end of the demo.
Now, I'm going to go
back to some slides.
So this analytics service
is powered by Chatbase.
And Chatbase is this new
up-and-coming service
for analytics.
We're currently in
early access program.
So people can go on
Chatbase.com and request access
if they want even more
detailed analytics
than what I've shown right now.
So let's talk about the
detail, the analytics.
Next slide.
ILYA GELFENBEYN: Oh, there
is the clicker, there.
OFER RONEN: OK.
So, yes.
So Chatbase is all for chat bot.
What we've learned from talking
to tens of chat bot developers
over the last few months, some
of the top ones out there,
is that--
oh, that's what I mean.
OK.
We learned that traditional
analytics just don't cut it.
That because chatbots
are built differently,
they're multi-turn
experiences that
are expected to handle
variable kinds of input,
you can't just use a normal web
site or app analytics product.
And so talking to
all these developers,
we learn best
practices and input it
all into this
easy-to-use service.
So just like API.AI, Chatbase
is also cross-platform.
Because what we learned
is that developers
like to deploy on
multiple platforms.
They don't just do one, usually.
And so, being able to
compare metrics per platform
is really powerful and the
way that developers often
use this is, they
might have, let's
say, a voice agent that
has good engagement.
But let's say, their
text-based one is suffering,
is not doing as well.
You can zero in on that
and fix the text one.
And so let's talk about
the bagel example more.
So you've deployed
your bagel agent
and now you want to know
how well it's growing.
That's often the first
question you ask.
And so, we can give
you some metrics
that are familiar, like active
users and number of sessions.
But also you can see
pro-intent what's going on.
Like the kind of
growth you're getting.
On the engagement side,
you can see how deep people
went into the conversation.
But also we heard that
a lot of chat bots
drive traffic to their
existing web site or app.
So we show that kind
of activity, as well.
In the bagel example,
maybe you wanted
to see the nutritional
details of the bagel.
You know, that might
be on the web page.
So that's captured.
And then, with
retention, we show you
cohorts that can
filter by intent.
And so you can zero in on
particular repeatable actions
around specific things
in your chatbot.
Also, on the retention
side, especially
for text-based agents, you
often send notifications
to reengage the user.
And so, we show you how
those campaigns are doing
and you can AV test it there.
But what we learn is
that the real work
of optimizing an agent is
really done at the intent level.
And so, we show
you those details.
And you can see, in
this case, with bagels
that after the-- a lot of people
did the initial ordering, 9,000
people, or 7,000.
And then, a lot of
them rejected the drink
up sell or cross-sell.
And then left the session.
They didn't complete.
They didn't get through
the order at phase.
And so you can start to see
a story of what's happening
and where people
are dropping off.
And you also see response time.
Sometimes people are
exiting, let's say,
the drink up sell
was taking forever
to get back to the user.
We show you 50% or
90% response time.
And that can be really
useful at the intent level.
But we went even further.
Developers told us
that looking at a table
can be daunting, especially as
you have more and more intents.
And so what we do
is, we automatically
generate something we
call the session flow.
And what that is, is that
is the sequence of intents
that the users went through.
And if we look at the
example we talked about,
you can see that the places
where people dropped off.
And where this is
useful is really
to help you understand what
steps should optimize along
the way.
And also, this is
that 10,000 foot view
of what are people really
doing in my chatbot.
So let's talk about one of
our early access partners
and the benefit they
saw from Chatbase.
So, Viber is a messaging
app with over 800
million registered users.
And they have their own chat
bot platform with their own bots
and also third party ones.
And they realized pretty
quickly that normal analytics
wasn't going to work for them.
And so they started using us.
And for one of
their top chat bots,
which is like a digital
sticker sharing bot,
you can send your friends
stickers of cats, dogs,
and so on.
They saw that really
popular queries
were having high exit rates.
And so they optimized those.
And after that, they saw a
35% bump in total queries,
in query volume.
So I'm really excited
to hear more stories
about how some of you out there
will benefit from Chatbase.
And in terms of next steps,
go API.AI and build an agent.
You can also go to
Chatbase.com and request access
to the early access program.
We also have code labs.
So whether online or
here on the premise,
you can try a code lab both
for Chatbase and for API.AI.
If you're building
actions, then please join
our vibrant community online.
And at this point, we're going
to open it up for questions.
If we don't get
to your question,
please stop by our
sandbox right out here
in the assistant space.
And we can answer it there.
And also demo for
you both products.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]